bonsoir à tous merci pour vos chaleureux
applaudissements à vrai dire quand on
m'a dit que je devais intervenir à tlx
j'étais très content j'avais de la joie
au coeur juste et fier je le disais oui
fallait le faire mais à deux jours de la
conférence ça n'allait pas j'étais sous
pression et à la veille hier par exemple
je ne dormais plus je me suis dit est-ce
que c'est pas mieux d'abandonner est-ce
que c'est ta place est ce que tu es
vraiment fait pour venir parler devant
les gens et partager avec eux je suis
chaud tu es tellement toute la nuit
monfreid c'est rêver il m'a dit qu'est
ce qui ne va pas je les dis bof je
comprends pas je n'arrive pas à trouver
de bonnes idées tout ça il me dit eh ben
si tu continues comme ça on peut offrir
un dîner ce record du chuchotement et ça
changera pas les choses fait vraiment
sous pression il m'a dit mais pourquoi
tu sous pression tu as accompli
tellement de choses je dis ouais mais
est-ce que je dois pas essayer de faire
plus de convaincre de tout ça il m'a dit
non ce qu'il faut comprendre avant tout
c'est ce désir de partager quelque chose
avec les gens et finalement j'ai compris
qu'il avait raison je me suis dit oui il
fallait que je parle et ironie du sort
je viens je devais parler du thème un
âge pour réussir et là je me présente
dans la salle parmi mes aînés qui sont
ici présents je me dis encore mais
qu'est ce que je fais ici
du haut de mes 22 ans je suis présent
parmi de ces grandes personnalités et je
dois intervenir sur intel si important
un âge pour réussir alors c'est la même
chose dans nos sociétés nous sommes tout
le temps sous pression de part et
d'autre part tout nous sommes nous
sommes sous pression un ami qu'on
rencontre qui nous dit à prendre
toujours pas mariée pour cette jeune
femme on peut comprendre à 33 ans vous
êtes là et votre camarade vient encore
33 ans toujours pas mariée il faut qu'il
y ait toujours ce genre de personne pour
nous rappeler où nous en sommes dans
notre vie et il y en a toujours autour
de nous 23 ans tu n'as toujours pas
d'emploi c'est toujours la même chose
qu'on entend on est tout le temps focus
et les choses et après tout on se dit
est ce que je peux y arriver
heureusement que pendant que je prends
parole lors levier tent parce que je ne
voudrais pas encore être sous pression
comme les gens sont souvent sous
pression avec l'âge et c'est souvent ce
qui se passe dans nos vies on pense
qu'il y en a jeux pour toutes choses et
on se met suffisamment de pression pour
ne pas comprendre que ce qui compte
c'est ce que nous posons comme action et
la société décide même à notre place
l'âge idéal pour réussir on nous impose
certain âge où il faut faire certaines
choses pour réussir et aujourd'hui avec
même le développement personnel on se
dit souvent qu'on est en retard on se
dit que white elle accomplit telle chose
at elle ajouté nous nous en sommes
encore là nous n'avons rien accompli et
ça devient encore une pression plus
stressante pour nous à cause de l'âge
qui pèse en général la notion d'âge
c'est important parce que même avec le
groupe canal+ on peut le voir lorsque
vous suivez la télé on pourra
déconseillé aux moins de 12 ans
déconseillé aux moins de 16 ans et
d'ailleurs je remercie canal+ pour cela
car je me souviens de l'un de mes
souvenirs d'enfance j'avais à peu près
sept ans je suivais la chaîne la chaîne
rtl9 si je me souviens bien il y avait
un film qui jouait le film c'était
robocop un policier qui était décédé
qu'on avait transformé en machine plus
tard je regardais ce film et j'étais
vraiment encouragé parce que je voyais
chaque fois ce policier franchir les
flammes et tout ça sans se brûler il
était intact je me suis dit bon
peut-être que moi je suis je suis
robocop qu'est ce qui se passe je prends
le couteau je le met aux fourneaux je le
trouve très bien je le mets au sol je me
dis je suis robocop alors je monte sur
l'estrade et je fais un bon
malheur à moi j'atterris sur le couteau
et ça me brûle le pied je me suis mis à
pleurer dans tous les sens je criais mon
frère qui est sorti en premier il me
voit en train de crier dit qu'est-ce qui
va pas je dis je me suis brûlé le pied
10 mai robocop ne pleure pas et pourtant
j'étais en train de pleurer
j'ai compris ce jour que wade chaque
fois qu on nous mettait des limites à
certaines choses pour elle nage ou quoi
que ce soit c'était parfois justifiées
mais est-ce que c'est tout ce qu'on doit
retenir en ce moment vous savez pour les
amis les frères et les parents que nous
sommes nous sommes souvent les gens qui
mettons la pression aux autres nous
sommes souvent les gens qui mettons
souvent trop de pression aux autres jeux
le rappelle souvent il y avait un voisin
qui se plaignait tout le temps de son
enfant qui disait pourquoi tu n'es pas
comme le fils du voisin pourquoi tu ne
travailles pas comme le fils du voisin
peut-être que c'est pas l'enfant le
problème c'est plutôt toi qui n'es pas
le voisin c'est pour ça que l'enfant ne
parviennent pas à se donner à fond et à
ressortir de bons résultats donc c'est
la même chose qui se passait avec moi
quand j'étais un peu plus petit je me
rappelle il faisait l'institution nelson
mandela j'avais de très bons résultats
mais ce n'était pas satisfaisant un
certain moment donné surtout aux
primaires
j'avais une baisse de régime
je me trouvais toujours 23e 32e ça
n'allait pas alors mon papa voyant cela
il ne m'a jamais offenser ne m'a jamais
comparé à un enfant du voisin il cède
une chose il fallait que je prenne un
peu plus de sérieux alors il m'a amené à
l'institution sainte marie de dixinn où
il m'a fait rétrograder d'une classe
je devais reprendre la troisième année
j'étais encore enfant mais ça m'avait
marqué parce que je devais reprendre une
classe pas parce que j'avais redoublé
mais parce que j'ai mon père a trouvé
que mes efforts étaient insuffisants
donc j'ai repris la 3e à sainte marie de
dixinn je me sentais pas à l'aise parce
que j'avais perdu pratiquement une année
mais ce qui s'est passé après c'est que
mon parcours j'ai pu remarquer qu'au fur
et à mesure me faisait confiance
j'améliorais mes résultats j'améliorais
mes compétences j'améliorais tout ce que
je faisais en termes d'études et au
collège aussi ça a commencé à aller j'ai
retrouvé la 6e 5e 10e 11e place mon papa
était très content de mes progrès de mes
résultats et pour la petite anecdote
toujours dans le parcours de la réussite
la première élection que j'ai eu à faire
c'était au collège l'élection des
délégués de classe je faisais la dixième
année on devait décider qui devait être
le délégué et je me rappelle que je
m'étais présenté avec d'autres amis
parmi lesquels celui qui fut délégué
tous le nom maurice et quand je me
présentais
il fallait procéder au vote et pendant
le vote j'ai eu le plus gros trauma de
ma vie parce que quand les votes se sont
effectués là je pense que la seule voie
que j'avais eue c'était une voix
et ironie du sort j'étais la seule
personne à avoir voté pour moi
donc je n'en revenais pas que personne
ne puisse me faire confiance en termes
de compétences de déléguer ou quoi que
ce soit j'aurais pu en vouloir à mes
amis mais je me suis dit c'est qu'il ya
quelque chose qui ne colle pas je devais
améliorer certaines choses je devais
travailler certaines aptitudes et
compétences et ce qui fut fait en 11e
année je devais me représenter pour
d'autres élections mais cette fois ci
c'était au compte de l'intérêt de clubs
qui est une des branches du rotary
international qui réunit des jeunes
entre 12 et 18 ans alors quand je devais
me présenter pour cette élection encore
j'avais encore le traumatisme de
l'élection précédente où je n'avais pas
encore gagné où j'avais zéro voix je me
suis dit bon ce que je vais faire c'est
me présenter à avoir le courage de le
faire mais ce qui s'est passé après
c'est que mon élection de zéro voix a
été l'élection qui m'a permis d'être élu
plus tard président de l'inter actes
parce que j'ai partagé se souvenir avec
les amis je leur fait comprendre que de
toute ma vie je n'avais jamais gagné
d'élection et que j'avais envie d'avoir
confiance en moi et que j'avais envie
qu'on me redonne confiance en moi ce qui
m'a valu être d'être le président de
l'interclubs conakry plus tard et après
l'intérêt que je me suis dirigé à lui
j'ai j'ai dirigé l'interactive est bio
et mes résultats ont commencé à
s'améliorer
11e j'étais toujours 2e 12e jeu panaché
entre la deuxième et la première place
terminal c'était la première place aussi
et la deuxième place j'avais commencé à
avoir de bons résultats de plus en plus
j'étais dans le tableau d'honneur
j'étais toujours au milieu des grands et
j'étais toujours en train de faire des
présentations des prestations en public
et ça allait de mieux en mieux je
m'améliorais en termes de compétences et
plus tard j'ai fait le bac et au bac
j'ambitionnais d'être le premier de la
république pourquoi pas le troisième
vous pouvoir avoir enfin une bourse une
bourse qui allait me permettre d'étudier
au moins au maroc mais là bas aussi j'ai
été 51e et jef et orientés à
l'université général lansana conté de
sonfonia en guinée ici j'ai voulu le
baisser les bras j'ai voulu abandonner
je me suis dit bon pourquoi je suis pas
allé au maroc étudier pourquoi je suis
pas allé de l'autre côté je suis encore
en guinée pour apprendre avec toutes mes
compétences et mon talent mais ce fut à
son faux n'ya que j'ai eu les plus
belles expériences de ma vie en 2017 en
dix ans angers dépit éloquence à
l'université de sonfonia et j'aimerais
que vous mmes applaudissent et pour cela
[Applaudissements]
donc j'ai été puis éloquence et je
faisais la première année il fallait se
présenter avec des étudiants qui faisait
la l3 des étudiants qui avaient déjà
presque fini qui avaient un parcours
très brillant et j'étais encore le plus
jeune parmi ses étudiants je me suis
présenté vous le concours d'éloquence je
ne pensais pas le gagner honnêtement
parce que je me disais que je n'avais
pas la carrure de ce qu'il fallait pour
gagner ce concours d'éloquence mais
finalement j'ai été choisi comme
l'étudiant le plus éloquent à
l'université de sonfonia et c'est là bas
encore qui a eu un nouveau déclic j'ai
affronté de nouvelles scènes j'ai
représenté la guinée à la coupe
panafricaine de débat de plus en plus
d'ouverture je les ai eus et toutes ces
ouvertures je les ai eus grâce à
quelqu'un qui m'a fait confiance au
départ grâce à mon père qui m'a fait
confiance malgré mes tard malgré tout ce
que j'avais il ne m'a pas mis de
pression il m'a fait comprendre qu'il
fallait que je me mette dans la
disposition et que ce n'était pas les
chutes qui comptait mais c'était
l'objectif à atteindre qui comptait donc
je me suis battu et la plupart du temps
les parents ce que nous ignorons c'est
que l'enfant c'est comme une plante une
plante qui a besoin d'engrais et chaque
plante à son espèce et chaque plante a
ses spécificités on ne peut pas vouloir
de notre fils qu'il soit ce que le fils
du voisin et on peut pas vouloir de
notre fils qui soit une une autre
personne et la plupart du temps même
avec mes amis qui n'arrive pas à se
déployer c'est que j'ai constaté c'est
que les parents imposent une carrière il
impose des choix ils sont plus
préoccupés par la réussite de leurs
enfants d'ailleurs ce qu'il pense être
la réussite de leurs enfants que par
ceux qui comptent pour l'enfant lui même
on n'a plus le temps de regarder à ce
que l'enfant représente non regarde
toujours à ce qu'il ya autour à la
comparaison et finalement ça détruit
l'estiment de l'enfant et pour cela il
faut comprendre que ces enfants que nous
sommes nous sommes des plantes qu'on
doit arroser et chaque plante à son
espèce et produit en son temps et en sa
saison on ne peut pas vouloir la même
production pour un bananier que mendier
donc il faut apprendre à donner du temps
aux enfants de sade de s'adapter à
poursuivre leur but est surtout allé
faire confiance peu importe ce qu'ils
entreprennent vous savez il est bien
possible de recadrer son enfant on n'a
pas toujours besoin d'imposer un choix
son enfant il suffit juste de l'écouter
quand il décide d'embrasser une carrière
vous lui dites oui c'est bien d'embraser
cette carrière mais est ce que ça te
rapporte çà çà çà çà et mettre l'enfant
devant les faits accomplis
c'est ça devient un peu compliqué parce
que nous décidons souvent à la place des
gens ce que ça devrait être leur
réussite et c'est souvent pour ça que
les gens n'arrivent pas à se déployer
peu importe leur âge et même pour les
personnages et on n'arrive souvent blâmé
des gens parce qu'ils n'ont pas réussi
telle ou telle chose un certain âge on
peut remarquer que de grands penseurs et
de grandes personnalités ont réussi un
peu plus tard que d'autres on aime tous
le poulet qui a essaimé colonel sanders
est à 63 ans qu'il a pu le mettre sur
pied et même si mark zuckerberg a réussi
à 19 ans nous avons d'autres personnes
qui n'ont pas réussi à se taire comme
samuel l jackson qui a eu son premier
rôle à 43 ans comme pour nous dire que
chacun a son parcours son chemin en
fonction des défis qui s'offrent à lui
et en fonction de ces réalités et c'est
pour ça il ne faut pas toujours penser à
envier quelqu'un d'autre par rapport à
ce qu'il fait
d'ailleurs nous définissons parfois très
mal la réussite on confond souvent
succès et réussite parce que le succès
c'est ce que les gens pensent de nous et
de nos réalisations alors que la
réussite c'est ce que nous pensons de ce
que nous avons accompli nous seuls
pouvons savoir si nous avons réussi ou
pas car notre réussite part de nos
objectifs et non ce que les gens disent
de nous et souvent ce qui me fait mal
c'est que chaque fois qu'on parle de
modèle de réussite dans nos sociétés on
pense à quelqu'un forcément qui a une
voiture qui a une maison qui a une
entreprise qui a un job il ya une belle
femme qui a des enfants pourtant ce
n'est pas que ça la réussite chaque fois
qu'on emprunte un chemin il faut qu'on
sache qui a quelques uns qui a frayé le
chemin chaque fois que moi j'en prends
un sentier je me dis si j'emprunte ce
sentier c'est parce qu'il ya des gens
qu'ils ont frayé si je m'exprime
aujourd'hui si je parle aujourd'hui si
je suis fait appel lien c'est parce
qu'il ya des gens qui ont donné leur vie
pour ce sacrifice pas forcément des gens
qui étaient fortune et pas forcément des
gens qui était replacé mais des gens qui
se sont distingués les uns que les
autres et le plus souvent même dans les
films on retient souvent plus facilement
le nom des acteurs que des producteurs
et des réalisateurs
je fais tout de suite un test avec vous
vous verrez que vous le tenez plus le
nom de certains acteurs que des
producteurs mais ce qu'on ignore
réellement dans la rue si tu sais que
c'est un peu comme une production de
films derrière chaque film il ya le
réalisateur le scénariste les
maquilleuses les costumiers qu'on ne
voit pas mais tout autant que les autres
tout autant que les acteurs il contribue
aussi à la réussite et à la bonne
production du film mais souvent ce sont
des gens oubliés et si nous sommes même
ici présents au stade elle c'est parce
qu'il ya une équipe qui s'est battu une
équipe qui n'est pas tout le temps sous
les projecteurs mais une équipe qui se
bat il se dévoue pour la réussite de
tous donc moi je pense que la réussite
c'est chaque fois que nous nous
disposons à construire un idéal chaque
fois que nous participons à la
construction d'un idéal par les voitures
que nous avons pas les maisons que nous
avons sinon nous occultons tous les
autres qui se battre autour de nous
si nous sommes si bien accueillis dans
un hôtel c'est qu'il ya un gardien qui a
bien voulu faire son travail n'at-il pas
plus de mérite que les autres est ce que
parce qu'il est gardien ça veut dire
qu'ils ne participent pas à quelque
chose dans l'hôtel c'est souvent les
petits rôles qui font les grands essais
les rôles que moi je juge les plus
nobles parce que les celeron qui permet
tout on se surpasse qui ne sont pas
donné à tout le monde vous êtes agent de
sécurité vous tenez des bouts du du
matin jusqu'au soir pour la sécurité de
certaines personnes vous n'arrivez pas à
dormir donc moi je pense que c'est pour
moi ces gens les modèles de réussite ces
gens qui se battent à chaque fois pour
que d'autres et l'idéal parfois dans
l'homme qu'on ne voit même pas qu'on a
parfois du mal à saluer qu'on a parfois
du mal à traiter avec considération même
mais pourtant autant que nous il
participe à la réussite d'autres
personnes donc la réussite en quelque
sorte c'est les mêmes que nous nous
donnons chacun avec les autres pas
forcément celui qui se dit j'aime le
plus mais chacun auprès des autres c'est
quand nous nous donnons les mains que
nous construisons quelque chose donc peu
importe notre âge peu importe notre
niveau que nous soyons gardien agents de
sécurité moi je pense que le plus
important c'est de comprendre que nous
participons à l'édifice de quelque chose
et c'est ce qu'ils révèlent en quelque
sorte notre personne notre idéal et je
dirais aussi que s'ils avaient un âge
pour eux ici au moi je pense que l'âge
pour réussir c'est l'âge où on apprend
de nos erreurs on apprend de chaque fois
que nous avons chuté
s'il y avait un âge pour réussissait un
âge où on apprend se découvrir avec soi
même parce qu'il n'y a pas de réussite
sans découverte avec soi on se découvre
ont choisi une direction on décide de ne
pas abandonner et on arrive à un
aboutissement parce que c'est en fait ça
la réussite nous décidons nous avons une
vision nous arrivons à un aboutissement
beaucoup de personnes se bat ça et là
mais n'arrive pas à exploser au grand
jour pas parce qu'ils sont pas si bien
que ça d'ailleurs un stand disait que si
on devait comparer le poisson sa
capacité à grimper rona bon sens on
dirait qu'il est nul pourtant quand on
le met dans l'eau on se rend compte que
le crois sont fait toute la différence
donc c'est au fait essayer de trouver
l'environnement dans lequel on se sent
le mieux le couloir dans lequel on se
sent le mieux se donner à fond pour
aider se donner à fond pour construire
quelque chose et peu importe si on est
reconnu de par des livres d'histoire ou
pas le plus important c'est ce que nous
donnons à la société merci
[Applaudissements]